Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my legends of tomorrow
episode eight video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet.
A lot of reverse flash making plans against
future flash Barry.
So I'll explain what's going on there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway going
on right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything during the
break is a couple really weird things that
are happening with legends of tomorrow when
all the DC shows come back in January like
it's moving to a new night it will air after
the flash but I'll remind everyone at the
end of this and I have a flash trailer video
that I'll post this weekend and I'll remind
everyone again and that so no worries legends
of tomorrow does the Untouchables it's called
the Chicago way it's all about Al Capone big
gang era Chicago so what inappropriate episode
to Marshall the Legion of doom.
Malcolm Merlin makes his entrance Capt.
cold the parents to was having a visitation
ghost of Christmas past, present, future style
they kind of did that with an arrow episode
a couple seasons ago they did ghost of past,
present and future as the midseason finale
like as their Christmas episode so if you
like.
They did a really good job with all the Chicago
stuff.
It was a lot of fun.
They did great costumes.
They did a good job of molding the legends
of tomorrow.
Music, to 1920s big band style like they had
a version of the theme song played by a big
band in the background and it was a big mythology
episode so sometimes you have adventures that
are really one off.
They don't really push the story forward.
Then you have the mythology episodes you have
like the Legion of doom explaining what it
is that they're trying to do you learn all
about the talismans in the Spear of destiny.
So this is huge.
Obviously you know about the infinity gems
in the marvel universe just really powerful
artifacts that they can use to reshape reality
like time space the soul.
So in the DC universe.
They do have a lot of very powerful magical
artifacts with the way the reverse flash wants
to use the Spear of destiny is is kind of
like the reality gem he wants to use it to
reshape reality to suit his design and the
producers of already explained what that is
so bringing it all the way back to the flash
season one in for a lot of you flash comic
book readers.
This is nothing new there is one thing that
the reverse flash wants to do in his lifetime
and that is to kill Barry Allen without erasing
himself in the timeline that's like his one
thing that he wants to do.
He is stuck on it every action he takes is
a step closer to that goal.
So just because he's on legends of tomorrow
forming this alliance the Legion of doom,
all talk about that in the second because
I feel like the reverse flash doesn't have
friends.
So they've soften them up just a little bit
for this, but the reverse flash really just
wants to get rid of Barry that's what he's
going to use the Spear of destiny for to rewrite
a new reality without Barry Allen and it so
that is what's going to be the season finale
their 17 episodes this season.
They actually added a couple episodes during
the middle of the run because the network
like what they were doing so much like okay
people are watching this now it's a good show.
Please give us some more episodes on the back
and so they ordered like four extra episode
so is basically like an extra month of legends
of tomorrow in the spring when everything
comes back but some of my other favorite things
from this episode were heat wave and vixen
teaming up as Bonnie and Clyde like he was
trying to teacher that sometimes it's more
fun to be the bad guy and she's trying to
show him that he is not all that bad like
he wants to be a team player, but it's not
in his nature.
So that's where you get the Capt.
cold entrance was a lot of fun seeing him
back.
But he's headspace Capt.
cold.
So is not back physically Vicki still dead
in this continuity because it's the comic
books you can bring people back in all kinds
of ways just look at the people over on arrow
I want to spoil that if you haven't seen the
arrow midseason finale delicious a surprise
comic book twist in the final moments that
episode, but if you haven't watched the flash
season one in the while they had a couple
Easter eggs for that where he stole Martin
Stein's DNA to become him like he said I've
change this a little it used to just kill
people now which is going to be excruciatingly
painful.
So if you remember season one eobard Thawne
took the DNA from original Earth one Harrison
wells became him and that's how you get to
reverse flash in disguise for the entirety
of season one.
So when he did that to Harrison wells it turn
them into this desiccated corpse.
So that's what he was doing to Martin Stein
if that wasn't clear.
But they finally make use of rip Hunter's
secret room a weapon, so they have a speedster
gun.
They can finally fight the reverse flash in
this is the first episode where they actually
refer to him as the speedsters they learn
who he is, but they don't know a whole lot
about you bar Thawne yet next big thing.
Malcolm Merlin.
So it was fun to see Jon Barrowman back but
I didn't really like the way they used him
in this episode he seems fairly low on the
totem pole within the Legion of doom.
Like there the rod he's the character like
he's like look I'm in a make a deal with you,
we can get everybody back I can get Tommy
back you can get Laurel back most of the planning
in the episode was thanks to him that he played
Elliot Ness against the legends, so that they
can get back on board their ship and just
destroy it get the amulet and get off the
entire reason for this was just to get the
other piece of the amulet, so they could use
the compass to find the Spear of destiny.
So obviously Sara does not take Merlin's deal
and she has like a big row with Martin Stein
over his daughter, but eventually he says
you know, maybe it doesn't matter so much
that we protect the timeline.
Maybe our family is more important, so that
just leaves you a little back door for her
to maybe save Laurel.
Maybe there's some big explanation with what's
going on on arrow so I'll talk more about
that when I do arrow videos just because some
you might not be watching that right now but
a lot of this all flows together with what's
happening on the flash and arrow.
So it helps if you watch all three shows but
thus far like for this first half of the second
season.
I feel like the shows much better than having
a lot more fun just jumping around two different
genres different periods and DC history.
And they're making use of a really big mythological
things like the Spear of destiny if you can
have a big team up show like this then obviously
your finale has to be huge that whatever the
villains are trying to do has to be big.
So Spear of destiny is about as big as you
can go like the next biggest thing would be
for the reverse flash to steal the helmet
of fate and become a speedster Dr. fate that
was actually a pretty bad ass costume, but
that actually reminds me.
So the reverse flash, especially in that intro
scene with a kind of teased him talking to
Al Capone for his like what is this Halloween
and it is kind of chocolate each other will
it's really Christmas so my one problem with
what they're doing with the reverse flash
right now is that he is way too nice he doesn't
have friends like he refers to the Legion
of doom as his friends like it seems almost
like he in Damien Darhk or old drinking buddies
now but you bar Thawne is one of those people
that so smart and feels he is so much smarter
than everyone else he just can't talk to anyone
he just a complete ass hole he just spends
most of his time putting others down or trying
to kill people or telling them to shut up.
That's why you don't see him working with
a lot of people in the flash comics usually
is him by himself acting alone like some grand
plan during those brief periods where he is
forced to work with other people.
He absolutely hates that he cannot stand anyone
else so with anything what I'm hoping to see
from the reverse flash on legends of tomorrow
is that eventually the Legion of doom will
just eat itself alive like you bar Thawne
is the most powerful person on their team
everyone else is a good fighter but he is
the only one that has legit superpowers.
So what I'm hoping is is if somebody ends
up killing Damien Darhk or killing Merlin
again are seemingly kill them.
It'll be the reverse flash to do, it won't
be the heroes evil will turn on itself let
me know in the comments what you guys think
of the episode and what you think about them
using the Spear of destiny to a race Barry
Allen from the timeline now I say that, but
that's only the reverse flash is planned.
Malcolm Merlin does not care about Barry Allen
Damien Darhk also does not care about Barry
Allen at all.
So future war the savitar stuff the reverse
flash's plan that'll all play out in the back
half of the season will learn more about it
but that gets into some flash storyline stuff
that's happening on that TV show it all kind
of blends together so that's why it helps
a lot if you watch the other TV shows, which
is like a normally would if they do a storyline
from another TV show I'll try to explain it.
Just in case you guys haven't watched it.
So no worries and just a reminder legends
of tomorrow is going to come back January
24.
That's the same not to the flash is coming
back.
It's an air right after the flash so the new
schedule will be flash on Tuesdays then legends
of tomorrow then Arrow no DC TV on Thursdays.
I think the reason they did that is, to try
and boost ratings, just because the flash
is really strong lead-in and they want to
have like all their DC TV shows group together
so if you think it's weird is really just
a ratings thing no worries.
So was can happen next is I'll post that flash
trailer videos that I'll post my Spider-Man
Q&A that will have some game of thrones walking
dead finale on Sunday but congratulations
to this week's flash ring giveaway winner
Carson Allen please private message me on
the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video.
I'll just remind everyone when I post that
flash trailer video while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my Spider-Man
trailer videos and you can click here to learn
all about savitar on the flash thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight!